wir sind unterwegs im okavango-delta
botswana
ranger cady zeigt uns dieses
einzigartigen naturparadies
alles leben hängt am wasser an den
vielen verzweigungen des okawango
flusses die sich durch das delta winden
wenn dieses wasser verunreinigt wird
dann könnte das viele tierarten aber
auch pflanzen und gräser betreffen sie
könnten sterben
fast alles was er hier bringt der
okavango fluss bevor er in das
okavango-delta mündet fließt der durch
namibia dort hunderte kilometer
flussaufwärts ist diese gefahr jetzt
real im norden namibias bot die
kanadische firma recken afrika nach öl
bislang sind es probebohrungen doch
geplant ist die kommerzielle förderung
im großen stil die firma vermutet im
kongobecken ein riesiges ölvorkommen
sollte irgendetwas schief gehen ist das
sensible ökosystem der ganzen region in
gefahr rec in afrika spielt die risiken
herunter
es gibt immer risiken aber sie werden
komplett gemindert durch gute ölbohr
praxis und modernste technologie ist
wirklich die praxis an dieser bohrstelle
wirkt wenig vertrauenerweckend die grube
in der das abwasser des burg prozesses
aufgefangen wird wurde nicht mit einer
plane abgedichtet das gilt international
als gängige praxis damit keine
giftstoffe aus dem abwasser in den boden
eindringen
braig in afrika geriet dafür massiv in
die kritik und macht trotzdem so weiter
auch die grube bei der nächsten
bohrstelle ist nicht korrekt abgedichtet
wie unsere aufnahmen belegen auch beim
thema land wurden vorschriften
missachtet die genehmigung der gemeinden
vor ort lag noch nicht vor da fingen die
arbeiten bereits an das musste andreas
movano erleben auf seinem land hat
recken afrika die erste bohrung
durchgeführt hier hat der mais angebaut
seinfeld wurde ihm einfach genommen es
war ein schock als plötzlich die leute
hier auf dem feld an kamen sie haben
alles eingeebnet und angefangen zu
bohren rackern afrika hat nicht mit uns
gesprochen sie haben uns missachtet und
geringschätzig behandelt
das land ist abseits des flusses sehr
trocken die armut ist groß die hütten in
denen andreas may war nur mit seiner
familie lebt liegen direkt neben dem
einstigen maisfeld geblieben sind ihnen
nur noch einige pflanzen er fühlt sich
als habe man ihnen eine löwengrube
geworfen sagt er eine entschädigung habe
er nicht bekommen wie weiter weiß er
nicht
ich habe gar nichts um meine familie und
mich zu ernähren ich denke darüber nach
loszuziehen und land zu suchen damit ich
meiner familie helfen kann aber ich weiß
nicht wo ich land bekommen kann
[Musik]
heute ist max william bureau q zu besuch
auf ihn setzt andreas all seine hoffnung
maximilian büro kümmert sich um
umweltbelange in der region vertritt
mehr als 10.000 menschen viele machen
sich jetzt sorgen dass auch sie ihr land
verlieren sagt er am meisten angst dabei
macht ihnen die frage welche
auswirkungen die bohrarbeiten auf das
grundwasser haben so wie andreas müssen
viele hier für jeden liter wasser
kilometerweit laufen
jeder tropfen ist kostbar
wenn das grundwasser kontaminiert ist
dann können wir es nicht nutzen und
namibia ist ein trockenes land
wir begleiten mexiko in die hauptstadt
windhuk er spricht vor einem ausschuss
im parlament kämpft für die rechte von
menschen wie andreas erklärt dass die
menschen in den dörfern kaum oder gar
nicht über das projekt informiert wurden
wir haben große angst
wir sind quasi blind wir wissen nicht
was auf uns zukommt
denn recken afrika ignoriert uns
hier treffen wir auch methoden junior
ist geologe hat früher für ölfirmen
gearbeitet und die seiten gewechselt
jetzt waren der vor den risiken und
bestätigt die sorgen was das grundwasser
angeht jede einzelne bohrung durch
grundwasser sei ein risiko
du muss sicherstellen dass die
schutzhülle nicht nur dick genug ist
sondern dass auch der zement der die
schutzhülle in position bringt richtig
arbeitet und dass die schutzhülle über
die zeit nicht rostet zu dass stoffe aus
niedrigeren toxischen oder salzhaltigen
bereichen an der hülle hochsteigen und
ins grundwasser einbringen können jedes
mal wenn du durch grundwasser borst
riskierst du eine kontaminierung des
grundwassers
die namibische regierung die an dem
projekt beteiligt ist will nicht über
risiken reden sie verweigert das
interview erklärt schriftlich die probe
bohrstellen lägen weit entfernt vom
kongo fluss und dem okavango delta
doch das ist nur die halbe wahrheit denn
die frage ist was passiert wenn hier im
großen stil öl gefördert wird das
lizenzierte erkundungsgebiet liegt über
hunderte kilometer direkt am kavango
fluss es zieht sich entlang des flusses
bis nach botswana hinein fast bis hin
zum delta
der kavango ist die lebensader der
region für tiere und menschen wenn der
fluss verunreinigt würde wäre das eine
katastrophe sagt der ökologe markt
wächst
die wildtiere sind vor allem im unteren
teil des flusses in der gegend des mango
parks was wichtig ist der mango und der
barto park können ohne den fluss nicht
existieren aber die größte bedeutung hat
der fluss für das delta in botswana
es würde sterben wenn mit dem fluss in
irgendeiner form schindluder getrieben
wird
das okavango-delta ist eines der größten
feuchtgebiete afrikas hier sind nicht
nur die sogenannten big five heimisch
sondern auch unzählige andere tier und
pflanzenarten manche von ihnen bedroht
ohne das delta wäre es schwer bestimmt
daten zu erhalten sagt katie unser
ranger er hofft dass die regierungen von
namibia und botswana
verantwortungsbewusst handeln und dieses
einzigartigen naturparadies höher
bewerten als mögliche gewinne im
ölgeschäft
[Musik]